And everybody, welcome to another Zoom call.
Um, just some rebellingers.
I always look at the members homepage.
To see if there's any updates.
Um, and one update this last week is,
so you members get a discount on your,
your follow up visits and such with me.
Well, for a year, we extended that same discount to non members,
just because of it's actually over a year to half.
I think it was, but the recession and issues that were going on,
that we extended that discount.
Other people went back to our old pricing for non members.
So you have to call in for your appointments.
That's the bottom line because if you try to do online scheduling,
you know, we can only have one fee for that.
And it's too difficult.
So it's back to the old fee because we have a lot.
We had less old members.
Use the online platform. So that's just how we did it.
So just call in for appointments.
So you can get the discount.
If by chance you happen to schedule online,
then we will have to call you and give you the discount.
So okay, so make sure as I go through these,
I'm going to go through these questions.
First for the most part,
you go ahead and chat in questions like somebody just did,
but we'll get through the questions that were sent in first.
First question.
I did retesting a few months ago and started some new supplements for anxiety and depression.
I really haven't noticed any huge difference in that matter.
I have a lot of supplements and it's very costly.
So just to be on other supplements.
Just so I just want to be on the supplements that focus on cancer.
What would be your recommendations?
Well, the supplements that I may have recommended if you asked me
or some recommendations for anxiety and depression,
typically the first thing that I recommend is adaptogens.
So adaptogenic supplements can help balance your hormones,
can help balance your adrenal hormones,
your pituitary hormones, your thyroid.
It can really help with anxiety and depression.
If those did not help, there's another cause.
So anxiety and depression can also be from excess glutamates in the brain.
So there's other things that you can focus on and those can be dietarily.
So make sure you're not getting exogenous glutamate.
It's in a lot of different foods, a lot of different processed foods.
It's pretty hard to go out to eat and get like a chidees or tie
or something like that that you're not getting glutamates in it.
There's a lot of glutamates in a lot of different spices,
a lot of different sauces, a lot of different processed foods
and that will definitely increase anxiety,
OCD issues and increase depression.
There are some programs on your life for anxiety and depression
so that should be a go-to thing as well.
Always with your life, you have a lot of programs on there
for all sorts of different conditions.
Let that be your go-to for any other comorbidities
other than your overnight programs for your cancer.
So for sure, use that as well.
Is dox gelatin that contains glycine a good thing for me to take
if so how much and how often?
So this was asked by a person with breast cancer
and I would answer no.
It's probably not a good thing for you to take.
First of all, dox, brand gelatin.
It's probably highly processed.
It's probably not a good source as a nutrient.
Now, there may be some books out there,
especially older books that will say take dox gelatin.
It's really good as a source of collagen for your nails
and your skin and your hair and such.
You're just better off taking a good clean source collagen
if that's what you're looking for.
I wouldn't use dox gelatin as a supplement.
No.
What does it mean when you have an increase in bilirubin?
So, bilirubin is a,
shows a function of your liver really.
So, bilirubin is, when you get your bilirubin measured in your blood,
if you could have a total bilirubin
or you could have an indirect bilirubin.
So, typically your total bilirubin is composed of,
what's called your indirect bilirubin.
Your indirect bilirubin is also called your un-pagigated bilirubin.
And that circulates in your blood on the way to the liver.
And then you have direct or conjugated bilirubin.
And that is when your liver makes the bilirubin water soluble
to be deposited into the bile to be then go through the bile duct
and the bile bladder and in the, in the small intestine.
Remember, your bile is what brings all the toxins from your liver
down into your small intestine as well.
And then your bile also contains lipase to help break down fats.
So, but bilirubin is the breakdown of hemoglobin.
So, when you have an increased bilirubin,
it can be because you have a breakdown in hemoglobin.
So, you could have a breakdown in the blood disorder
where you have what's called hemolysis,
where you have a breakdown in red blood cells in the blood.
That's less common.
Most of the time, when you see an increase in bilirubin,
it's because of a blockage of the bile duct.
So, remember, your bilirubin will ultimately go through the liver
and become made water soluble in the liver and then go through in the bile
to the small intestine.
That is the most common, especially for a person who has cancer,
but a person has increased bilirubin, you're concerned with a blocked bile duct.
Now, you could have a blocked bile duct for multiple reasons
with a diagnosed cancer.
You're concerned with metastasis to the liver
and then a space-occupied lesion pinching the bile duct.
There's other possible reasons for a blocked bile duct,
but that's what the biggest thing you'd be concerned of
with having a current cancer diagnosis is a blocked bile duct.
When running the new programs on the Atelier Robin,
the light can be very dim and it can be hard to hear any noise.
Is this normal?
Yes, it is.
So, if I have updated your programs and you have an Atelier Robin,
I have put, I have rewrote literally every single program
of all the 1500 other programs I literally rewrote.
And I wrote them if it's appropriate in what's called the 11th harmonic.
And when you're running the 11th harmonic,
you're really running two frequencies at the same time.
The primary treatment frequency in the 11th harmonic of that treatment frequency.
And because you're running two frequencies, it really cancels out the noise
and the light will appear much dimmer, especially if you have our new bulb.
So, the new bulb carries more gas.
And the benefit of it, you're going to get more treatment from it.
And the other benefit of it is not going to be nearly as bright
because it's crystallized as well.
So, it's crystallized.
It's running the 11th harmonic and it's more gas in the bulb.
So, it's going to be a much dimmer bulb.
Matter of fact, I tell people, when we've had people call it,
this is, I don't think this is working, turn off your lights.
Now, I see it.
It's really hard to see at all in the daytime.
And the noise, especially if you're used to running a program
that's not on the 11th harmonic of the lower frequencies,
it's going to be much louder.
But now, running with the 11th harmonic,
some of the higher frequencies you can't even hear it running.
So, yeah, it's just to be aware of that.
What would be a fairly common side effect of taking Iver-Mectin and Venn-Bend is all?
Well, common thing that people can have is,
well, I would even say it's common.
A few people have said that they've had some stomach upset
if they've taken it out of empty stomach.
That has been corrected if they take it with food,
so that hasn't really been a problem.
The side effect that isn't necessarily a symptom,
it's more an objective finding,
is noticing an elevation, an AST, ALT, or alkaline phosphatase.
Those are liver enzymes.
And I believe that for the most part,
it's the Fenn-Bend is all that's doing that.
We have some people that have been just Iver-Mectin,
not Fenn-Bend is all,
and we haven't seen that phenomena at all.
We've had people on Fenn-Bend is all,
and not Iver-Mectin, and we have seen that phenomena,
and we have seen it with people on both.
So, I think it's the Fenn-Bend is all.
That can be more of a liver irritant.
Remember, your liver enzymes,
your ALT, AST, and alkaline phosphatase,
could be elevated for all sorts of different things,
but they certainly could be elevated if the liver is be irritated.
Let's say it that way,
so these things are still drugs.
Somebody asked a question a few weeks ago,
should I just take, you know,
I don't know if they're asking it for somebody else,
but they said, if I don't have cancer,
can I just take Iver-Mectin just, you know,
to help decrease my chance for cancer?
And I would say, no, I mean, these are still drugs.
I wouldn't take them prophylactically.
You're taking them for a purpose and for a treatment.
And it also means that you're not taking them
for the rest of your life, either.
I know there's websites out there that say that,
that our people are taking Iver-Mectin,
and they've been taking them since COVID days,
to keep from having COVID or to prevent from having cancer.
I just don't think that's the way to do it.
I don't think that's the way to use these medications.
I think they could have other side effects
that can be harmful to your body,
and they can certainly be toxic to your liver.
So, you know, doesn't mean that it's a bad drug.
It doesn't mean that you have to stop using it forever.
But if a person has elevated liver enzymes,
I want them to take a break on their femenazole.
You just have to take a vacation from it,
two weeks, four weeks, whatever we need
to get those liver enzymes back in order.
We certainly don't want to be using a medication
like this or a supplement, regimen,
or anything, you know, chemotherapy,
and have the drug itself have the,
quote unquote, cure of the cancer,
hurt you, and bring your demise.
That's just silly.
So, we just need to use things wisely,
and we need to be looking at an objective test
to see if it's negatively affected your body.
And if it is negatively affected your body,
you need to pause it for a period of time.
So, that's the wise way to use any medications.
One of the potential side effects
on my chemo-therapy treatment
is brittle bones.
Seems to be true in my case.
I have had two very minor falls
with the last bead about four months ago.
I broke four ribs each time.
Although I am much better,
they still haven't really healed
as evidenced by my CT scans.
Would you have recommendations
for supplements or diet that might be helpful
for healing or strengthening of bones?
Also, my wife is similar,
supplemental dietary question
pertaining to age-related osteoporosis.
So, the treatment for osteoporosis
or to help build bones that are damaged
via lytic metastasis
is not simply just to take calcium.
So, used to be thought years ago
that everybody should be on 1,500 milligrams of calcium.
That's what was promoted back in the late 80s and 90s.
It was just, it was incorrect information.
So, what it led to is people having,
you know, having, having, hardening the arteries,
having arterial sclerosis issues
and not actually increasing the density of bones.
So, how do you increase the density of the bone?
Well, do we need calcium?
Well, yeah, you do need minerals,
but nobody should be taking more than a few hundred milligrams
of calcium,
even of the good source of calcium,
you know, was worse back in the 80s and 90s people
were taking a poor source of calcium,
which was, which made,
which complicated the problem even be worse.
It's not so much the amount of calcium you're taking
because you could,
you really shouldn't take more than a couple hundred milligrams
of calcium per day,
even if you have horrible osteoporosis
or loss of calcium,
loss of bone density through the lytic metastasis.
What you need is MK7.
So, you need a vitamin K in the form of MK4, I mean.
So, most of the vitamin K that's out there
is going to be in the form of MK7.
That's not the form that you need to get calcium in the bone.
It's MK4,
and you need a very high dose of MK4
in order to get calcium in the bone.
I interviewed a gentleman about this.
I have a blog post about this.
The bottom line is,
there's only literally one supplement
that I recommend for osteoporosis,
osteopidia, or loss of bone density due to metastasis.
And that is a product called osteo-K-O-S-T-E-O-K.
We have it on our store.
I interviewed the gentleman who basically developed this
in one of the blogs,
so you could search for that as well.
But that's what you would take.
So, depending upon the amount of bone loss
and bone regeneration that you need to take place
is the dose that you take.
You take up to, I think, two to four these a day.
The person just has mild osteoporosis.
I suggest literally just one of these a day,
if you have a greater amount,
than you increase that for a period of time
and it's not taken forever.
So, osteo-K is the product for osteopidia, osteoporosis,
or bone loss due to metastasis.
Are you able to order ultrasounds,
or similar tests?
No, we're not a prescribing clinic,
not a licensed practitioner.
I can't order tests that require those types of licenses.
That's beyond our scope of practice.
I'm pretty sure that even a licensed chiropractor
in your area could probably order an ultrasound.
It depends on your area, that's your in as well.
I know if you're in, let's say,
the Twin Cities area,
your big metropolitan area,
ultrasounds can be had at local radiology clinics.
And those could be ordered by any licensed practitioner
in the state, including a chiropractic license.
There's no antropathic license in both states,
but there are some states you can actually just get an ultrasound
without having a doctor's order at all.
So, it just depends on the clinic.
I would search ultrasounds in your area.
I don't know, whoever asked this question went area.
They're living in and pumping the betropyloses.
Same line of thinking.
Can we prescribe hypervectin?
No, hypervectin has to be a prescription
by a licensed practitioner.
And you're going to have to find somebody that will give you
a prescription to a compounding pharmacy.
So, typically,
hypervectin is going to be available in 3 milligram
and 12 milligram doses.
That's how they're made.
If you need a dose that's different than that,
then you have to go to a compounding pharmacy
so that they will compound it in a dose of 30 milligrams
or whatever.
Now, I do know that there's websites out there
that allows you to just go on and order the hypervectin
and then they have a doctor that just calls you
and does a brief little consultation with you
and then they send you the hypervectin.
There's pros and cons so that the pro is obviously
that you're able to get that without finding
a local doctor that will work with you
if you don't have any local doctors
that are alternatively invited in your area.
The condo that is that typically it's fairly expensive.
I do know also that it is possible to order hypervectin
from overseas.
So, you do have to look at some websites
from that I have had multiple people
that have ordered hypervectin.
It all sorts of different dosages,
you know, 12, 20, 30 milligrams dosages
for fairly cheap from overseas
so that would be something to look into as well.
Second part of this question is hypervectin used
for lymphoma.
hypervectin can be beneficial for lymphoma.
So lymphoma is one of those cancers
that is kind of what would be called it
in between cancer because technically
it's a blood-based cancer similar to leukemia,
but it forms solid tumors.
So, hypervectin tends to be better
for the solid tumor type cancer.
So, hypervectin would, I would say,
would be a possibility for someone with lymphoma.
Would you recommend a liver or a gallbladder cleanse
when I am on a two-week vacation
from fenmen?
So, yes and no.
So, there's, I have on the detox course.
So, you can find the liver
and gallbladder cleanses on the detox course.
I think I have them as blog posts as well.
So, if you just search liver cleanser,
gallbladder cleanser, you'll find them on that too.
There's, I have them in two forms.
I have a mild, I think I call it mild and strong
or something like that.
Liver and gallbladder cleanses
because different cleanses that are out there.
The only thing that a person has to be careful
with a liver or gallbladder cleanse
is if they, if they have known gallstones,
they have to be careful.
That 99% of the people that would consider
doing a liver or gallbladder cleanse
are doing it because they have known gallstones.
So, I'm not saying that would prohibit you from doing it,
but you just have to be more careful of it.
Make sure you're using a hot pad over your liver.
Make sure you're using castorial packs
at different times over your liver.
Those are the things that can help decrease
the viscosity of your bile and help the bile flow.
Make sure if you're going to do that,
you are taking a binder
so that your bile needs stuff
if you're going to dump a whole bunch of stuff
out of your gallbladder and things you don't want to reabsorb that.
So, do, wouldn't it be advisable?
Well, I sure you can do that.
I don't think there's anything wrong with doing that.
I think it would be a wise idea because the purpose of
going on a vacation,
quote-a-quote, from using fentanyzol
is to help give your liver a break
and why it makes all sense
to support detoxification of the liver.
Also, consider besides the liver,
besides the cleanse,
besides the castorial packs
is make sure to coffee items
that would be extremely helpful, too.
In her book, The Smart Woman's Guide to Breast Cancer,
Dr. Jennifer Simmons mentions oxycodone
as possibly contributing to breast cancer.
What are your thoughts on this?
What might it alternative be?
Dr. Jennifer Simmons used to be a breast surgeon
for, I think, 19 years before she just hung up
to towel and went into doing more alternative things.
I have interviewed her several times on my podcast.
You can see those interviews on our feed
and our blog posts in your membership.
She's interviewed me on her podcast,
so we've become friends over the years.
It would be not just oxycodone,
it's all sorts of medications
that can contribute to all sorts of cancers.
How do they contribute?
Because medications have toxic side effects
and they can contribute to not only blocking
and damaging liver detox pathways,
so you're not going to detox other toxins
that you're exposed to as well.
And thereby the more toxins that you can't get rid of,
the more toxins you will hold,
and thereby could be causes of cancer
and causes of inability to help deal with cancer.
But different drugs have side effects
that can block tuber suppressor genes
and all sorts of things.
Now, I understand that if you have cold morbidities
or why would a person take oxycodone
because they have pain,
so if they have serious pain issues
and there are medications for that
and then the side effects could be worse
than the pain per se.
It's really hard to determine
whether beat an oxycodone was a cause
of the cancer, but it certainly isn't helping.
Is there an alternative to oxycodone?
Well, it's hard to find a natural alternative
to pain medication
because how strong those medications are
in blocky nerve impulses,
there's nothing naturally that's going to do quite the same.
So, you know, if a person has general pain
and inflammation, the first thing you think of
is the flavonoids, the curcumin,
high-dose curcumin, high-dose resveratrol,
Boswellia, you know, stiggy dental corset and et cetera.
But that's not going to cut very serious,
that's not going to cut real serious pain.
Well, is there other natural things
that you could do to help with pain?
Well, you could think of white willow bark
and different things like that,
but that's, again, that's not going to deal
with real serious pain.
From a natural perspective,
probably you're looking at something
like in the THC realm to help cut pain,
but that's not without side effects either,
because you'd feel very loopy and et cetera.
But we've had a number of people
that just did not want to go
with the medical pain-killing apparatus
that's out there,
and they would go with THC, don't.
This day at age, it's pretty easy to get THC
just about every state that's legal in it.
If you go to the different little THC stores out there
and you explain to them what you have going on,
you have pain from cancer,
they would be able to help you
to get a dosage that would be beneficial.
But that's probably from a natural pain
reducing standpoint THC,
which is the active form of the marijuana plant,
is going to be your best bet, I would say.
Now, I know years passed,
there's been information about CBD as a benefit for paid,
and we did everything under the sun trying to use that
for patients, and quite honestly,
it's just not effective enough with serious pain.
THC has been effective,
but it's not without side effects again.
What are some of the natural treatments
that can help bite her to positive breast cancer
if one is not going to go and do her septum therapy?
Well, everything that we have you on,
we test you on for your cancer is what we're doing.
So there isn't, with just like any cancer,
you could say the same thing,
what's the best thing for lymphoma,
or what's the best thing for multiple myeloma?
Well, it's very, it's rare that there is like a specific nutrient
that is going to help everybody with this specific cancer.
It's everybody's different,
so that's what we do the cheek swab testing,
and that's where we make our recommendations based upon that.
So I would say stick to your protocol,
and if it's mental, I don't know who has this question,
but if it's went a long time since we did a cheek swab test,
and if your cancer is currently not stable,
then I would say to recheck that again.
From everything I've read and heard about breast implants
after a mastectomy,
it would be greatly,
I would be greatly concerned about side effects,
especially with already having a large autoimmune condition
from late stage line,
what are your thoughts on this?
I would agree, I understand I'm not a female,
and it's hard for me to judge the emotional psychological effects
of not having a breast,
or breasts when you have them removed,
and you want to replace those,
and it's hard for me to say that a person shouldn't,
but from just from a health standpoint,
it certainly is not healthy to go and get implants.
I could say that without reservation,
does it mean that you shouldn't?
No, not saying that,
but it's not in the person's best health to go and get implants.
You're doing multiple surgeries
to have the skin stretched and to have the implant placed,
and you have healing that has to take place from that surgery,
so the more surgery that you do,
how your body heals from a surgery slash wound,
is to give off more growth factors.
I mean, I'm using the example of you just cut yourself.
You know, if you cut yourself with a knife by accident,
it's amazing how fast your skin heals,
but normally your skin cells will replenish themselves
on a normal basis about once every three months.
So as the mother cell gives off another cell,
and it dies, that takes place,
but once every three months is the normal apoptotic cycle
of your dermis,
but if you cut yourself,
it's amazingly wounds up scars up and heals
within a few days to a week,
maybe not completely healed, but it's wounded up
so that it's not an open cut in a very short period of time.
Why? Because in a case of an injury,
your body gives off growth factor,
in order to speed up that process of recovery,
thereby increasing the growth rate,
therefore increasing the replication rate of the cells
in order to heal.
Well, the more surgeries that we're going to get,
if we already have circulated tumor cells in the area
that were basically spilling gasoline slash growth factor on it,
you increase risk of reoccurrence is there.
I think, yes, you have to weigh it all out of that.
Okay, well, I'm going to go crazy,
and I'm going to feel horrible myself.
Everyone's going to make their own decisions.
I'm just saying from a strict health-related issue,
that's one factor that I would recommend against
having reconstructive surgery.
And then you bring up the fact that if you already have an autoimmune condition,
the ability of reacting from those silicon plastics
that are in that dub implant is there, is real.
It's not just pretend, and that can cause issues.
So, yeah, I am not a little story short,
I'm not a big fan of that,
though I know everybody has to make their own decisions there.
It's foolish to try to get rid of breast cancer
without doing a mastectomy since they can't do a lumpectomy
due to the cancer being labulated off for quadrants of the breast.
Thank you.
I'm trying, I'm willing to try via your program,
but I do not want to be foolish.
I totally agree with the way you worded this.
You don't want to be foolish.
But it doesn't mean you want to be foolish
and just doing what they tell you either.
So, you're trying to keep a balance there and use wisdom.
So, okay, I do, they're saying I should get a mastectomy.
I think I'm going to try some alternative therapies first
to see if I can do it without a mastectomy,
and then I'll be on my way through alternative therapies
that if this continues to grow,
and I decide to do a mastectomy,
then I'll be that much better positioned to heal.
I think that's wisdom.
I don't want to do a mastectomy,
but I'm willing to do a mastectomy to save my life
if that's what I have to do,
but I'm not willing to just jump into that hoop immediately.
I think that's, that's using wisdom.
So, if, in this case, let's say I start out an alternative protocol,
I'm doing the right, I'm doing different therapies,
I'm doing different supplements,
and let's say the cancer's continuing to grow.
Maybe it's slowed down a little bit.
Maybe it hasn't, but it's continuing to grow.
Now I'm going to decide I better go with do a mastectomy,
you're going to be in a much better position.
Or, let's say a better case scenario,
say it hasn't grown at all.
It's, you know, it's just stayed absolutely steady.
I think I'll just stay on this pathway for a period of time.
And maybe not do a mastectomy.
So those are the kind of things that you go through
in a decision-making process.
So I think, yes, I don't think you should be foolish
and just dogmatically take a position either side.
Okay, questions from the chat.
Is beta-glucan good for everyone?
I would say beta-glucan isn't bad for anybody.
Beta-glucan is a polysaccharide.
Typically, it's from heighten or it's from mushrooms.
That's what beta-glucan is.
So it's a polysaccharide.
Polysaccharides are indefinition in immune modulator.
And so if a person has a suppressed immune system,
they're trying to fight cancer.
It will help boost their immune system to be able to fight cancer.
So I don't think they're necessarily bad for anybody.
However, it's not just because something's not bad.
It will need to be taking everything.
So I think a better than beta-glucan is the evolved immune product
because that's got the polysaccharides in the exact right number.
So a polysaccharide is saccharides that are bonded together.
And I have written some things and did some videos on the evolved immune product.
The number of polysaccharides, which makes it the best to kill infections and to kill cancer cells.
Also, I started doing nicotine that Dr. Artis recommended is nicotine not good for some people.
I wonder if it made my cyst grow.
My cyst in my pancreas grew almost two millimeters.
I have been more sick than usual lately.
And my blood work has been better than the last two years.
So, yeah, I would be careful when there's a lot of videos out there on the internet.
I did see Dr. Artis's video that he said he was going to wear two milligram nicotine patch
the rest of his life because it's going to be good for him.
So I think sometimes these people will just make videos in order to get views.
Sometimes they just make videos to sound products.
I think more of it is just to sound just to get views and to keep up their audience.
I don't get this whole Instagram thing, this whole TikTok thing.
I literally told a couple of people I staff the other day that I just feel like I just want to shut down our whole Instagram account whatsoever.
It just bothers me so much. There's so much misinformation out there.
Now again, I'm not necessarily against doing the nicotine patch.
If it's helping you, but okay, it's just because there's a study that shows that it's good for this.
Because everybody should do that all the time. I mean, good assakes.
We'd all be on 4,000 different supplements.
So just be careful of those. That's why we do the zoom. That's why we do the cheek slomps.
So that you're not on 4,000 different supplements because you could find an article.
Literally, maybe not 4,000 probably.
You could probably find an article or multiple articles on at least 1,000 different supplements that say that there could be extremely beneficial for cancer or whatever condition you're dealing with.
Are you supposed to take all that stuff? It's just silly.
So just be careful of what you're doing out there.
Things can be bad for you too.
Besides the fact that how pure is those are those nicotine patches.
How pure are those? What other chemicals are in there?
What do they have to put in the product in order for it to work as a patch?
I just don't know what you're getting in this stuff.
So I don't know if that's what caused your sister to grow.
I can't say that. I don't know.
It's turmeric essential oil with the MSO rubbed right on my papyrus area.
Okay, to do three times a day.
So turmeric essential oil.
So I don't think so.
So I think about it. Okay, so what are the benefits of turmeric turmeric is a flavonoid edit.
The benefit is that it has cancer killing property.
So turmeric is curcumin remember has cancer killing properties in itself.
It's it's anti inflammatory has all these benefits.
But the essential oil of curcumin turmeric.
I don't know that's going to be more of an alkaloid.
I don't know if that has the same properties of the whole plant flavonoid.
So I don't know that that is.
It probably wouldn't hurt anything if you did it three times today.
And the DMSO itself can be anti inflammatory.
So I don't I don't think that's a wrong approach.
But I don't think you can count that as the benefits of curcumin.
Because I don't know much curcumin is actually in the turmeric essential oil.
Most essential oils are alkaloids.
And they have benefits, but I don't think the exact same benefit of the whole plant.
So I don't think there's anything wrong with that to answer your question.
But I don't know that you're getting the same benefit from taking turmeric.
If my RGCC said my cancer did not respond to Ivermectin.
Does that mean I wasted my time doing Ivermectin and fed bed is all.
Not necessarily.
I personally don't put a whole lot of stock in RGCC testing.
But that's just me.
So if you're doing the RGCC test.
Because you're putting stock in that test.
And then you're not doing what that test said to do.
I'd question that.
But I also think that if you believe in your heart and you're thinking about it and praying about it,
you feel led to do Ivermectin and fed bed is all that I think there's no nothing wrong with you doing that.
So I wouldn't say you're wasted your time.
You there's nothing wrong with experimenting with things like that.
Now this person that's asking this question has not been on RGCC for quite a long time.
But I don't know what you've listened to my stuff.
I've ever been to bed is all but even tonight I said if you're going to do Ivermectin and fed bed is all you better be tested.
Your liver enzymes in a regular basis like every two to four weeks.
Because you could have a spike in you could it can cause liver toxicity.
And you could have you know worst case scenario if you don't keep an eye on that and your liver enzymes go super, super high.
You could end up with liver failure and liver damage that's that could be very dangerous.
So you got to be keeping an eye on that.
That's my request to anybody who's doing fed bed is all at Ivermectin that you're testing that.
So I would say you test that and then you do a protocol and then you test you know if you can test for the benefits of that protocol.
You test whether if it's a cancer that you could observe like it's a tumor in your breast is it isn't improving?
No, it's not improving. It's doubled in size. Well, then maybe we need to change protocols.
If it's a cancer somewhere where you have to do a scan.
Well, that gets a little bit more complicated if it's a cancer where you could view two markers.
That's a little bit easier. So that's how you assess whether it's working or not.
In my rife should I be selected the version 6.4 program next to my name.
Yes, that's the latest one. That's the true rife 6.4 that would be your latest program. Yes, that's correct.
What's your opinion on sub grade minerals, sub grade minerals, also on going to cancer conferences.
I was going to doctor artists's workshop, but not sure if I should veer off by protocol.
I'm not sure what sub grade minerals are.
The minerals, the type of minerals that you should use are minerals that are bound.
The same way that they are in plants and in animals if you eat, you know, the minerals that you would get in in even in beef and things.
But you get most of your minerals through plants and minerals in plants are bound or double bonded to it'll be no acid.
So that's the way you should consume minerals.
The worst thing, I don't know what sub grade minerals are, but what's really has been popular in the last few years are these liquid minerals and these, you know, these.
C based minerals, coral, coral, sea minerals, that kind of stuff, that's ridiculous. You don't always eat dirt.
That's the plants eat dirt and they convert that soil based mineral into an amino acid double bonded mineral.
And then we consume that and that's well absorbed and well utilized.
We're not supposed to eat soil based minerals.
What's good to help reduce cysts size of pancreas? Well, we'd have to look at your protocol things.
Can I juice do a juice fast way to 100 pounds?
Well, again, you know, watch my videos on juicing diets.
If you're going to do a juice fast and your cancer is fed primarily through glycolysis,
you're basically feeding your cancer. So your juicing, carrot juice, apple juice, celery juice, you're going to have a very high glucose content that you're pouring down your throat.
And if your cancer is currently being fueled through glycolysis, you're basically just fueling your cancer.
So I would, you know, again, the person that's asking this, we haven't seen for a long time.
So you should probably do a new cheek swab test. We should do some rechecking and see what your protocol is.
Just FYI for anybody paying out a pocket for a procedure in the website, MDsave.com, provide games providers by procedure and location that offers a discount.
That's good helpful. That's good. I think you posted that to help that person who asked that question about ultrasounds.
So MDsave MDsave.com can be helpful to find a provider that would do an ultrasound near you. Thank you very much.
Again, could RSO, that's Rick Simpson oil helped by pancreatic cyst.
Can I use cystitis on my wife for my pancreatic cyst? No, cystitis is is infection in the bladder. That's not cyst.
So it's been a little misleading there.
And pancreatic cyst can be helpful with RSO possibly.
Is NAD and creatine okay to take?
Can I have a blog post on creatine, the pros and cons for cancer?
And by ultimate, the answer, quick answer to that is probably not.
NAD is nicotidamide and atocene. I forgot.
And that is usually considered an anti-aging supplement. NAD is a big new anti-aging supplements, a big new supplement to help in boost circulation for people that are working out.
It's big in the workout spectrum. It's big in the anti-aging spectrum.
It has positives and negatives to it for somebody who has cancer.
I would say if your cancer is in full remission, I don't think there's a problem with it.
Can be good for your heart to can boost at your oxide levels.
If your cancer is active, I would say no on NAD.
If your cancer is in full remission and you're looking for other things than I would say.
Looking for things, let's say you have heart issues or you have.
You're trying to work out, you're trying to increase circulation.
Then that's a possibility.
What could cause a bit to LIGO spots on your skin and what could I do about it?
Currently the thought for the LIGO is it's an autoimmune condition.
It has increased in our society by about 500% in the last 15 years.
Many people believe it's due to the amount of toxins in our foods.
The glyphosate contribution to that I think is a big contribution to that.
What could you do about it?
There's really not anything you could do about it.
Once you have it, you can try to work on detoxification pathways.
Everything that you're doing to try to get rid of glyphosate and get rid of other toxins.
But you're not going to be able to do anything to change the melanin in your skin.
So that's what it's affecting is the melanin production in your skin cells.
When should I consider doing another cheek swab?
So I'm often said that, well, first of all, when you start with me,
I always think it's good within 30 to 90 days to do another cheek swab
just to recheck things and make things work things or go into the right direction.
But it partly depends on the person.
So if the person starts with us, which isn't been very many people lately,
that are like real stable.
So most people that have started the last six months are more advanced and that I do suggest usually
when we do the initial cheek swab that we do a check with at least within 60 days to do another recheck.
If the person is stable and you're doing really well,
then I don't know that you need to do another cheek swab until differently.
So something's changed.
So I often have said that you use the cheek swab test like you feel like you need to go to the doctor
like something is up, something has changed.
If you're monitoring with blood tests, if you're monitoring with scans or however you're monitoring your cancer
and things feel stable or you feel like you're improving,
then I don't know that you need to do another cheek swab.
But if you feel like you're not going in the right direction, then by all means that's what you should.
So even if it's the last time to that, I just did a cheek swab 30 days ago,
but I feel like I'm crashing and going downhill, then there's nothing wrong with doing another one now.
So all depends on that person's symptoms.
My cancer is amino acid base.
So I think you're talking about what's feeding your cancer.
Well, it depends on how that was tested, who tested that, and when that was tested.
So if originally you got tested through me and it was your cancer was fed more through amino acids,
then it's been in how many years and then your cancer's changed.
So that's why you do another cheek swab test because fuel sources of your cancer changes.
So again, if you were like stable and you were doing great and you're doing fantastic,
then I don't know that you should really change anything you're doing or not make any drastic changes.
But if the cancer is growing, it's you know, move from dormancy to stability or you know,
you're doing pretty well to now not doing very well,
then that's when you have to get some recheck stuff and see what's going on.
Yeah, maybe a consult with me would be the right thing to do.
Yes.
Okay.
All right.
Well, thank you guys for another great Zoom call.
We will see you guys next week.
Make sure you get your questions in.
And next week I will still be taking patients next week,
but next week I am going to be gone.
For a week, still be taking emergencies,
but if we have to just go over labs or something,
it's going to hold off to the weekend for that.
All right.
And we still will have a Zoom call next week too.
So all right.
Have a great day.
Bye bye.